one day six actresses sorry so
suddenly what is the question since hello my
name is andrei i am 12 years old i speak
two languages spoken the n
xt game teach you what
t is to be irradiated what it's ok
what it brings a lot of things it
makes learning other languages easier for me it ca
also be perhaps the place
o effect but we tell you that those easie
to learn the language 7 motivates a littl
all the same asses
ment I  think it will help me in
the future for everyone not for employment
when I look at a file that a
person by himself for example
in business it can be it can
make things easier
there are also other professions  which opens
the translation the business of the
negotiation of this facility suddenly the
fact of having to be hired what and of
the job it is to many for example
to help them in the not for example and
nathan that is fine  to be five or seven
[Music]